wollen jetzt schalten zugriff chris
fleischhauer einem fdp mitglied der
heute seine mitgliedschaft zurückgekehrt
zurückgegeben hat beziehungsweise
aufgekündigt hat hallo herr fleischer
lösen in berlin sind sie jetzt ein
bisschen sie sind ausgetreten aus der
fdp heute nach dem manöver gestern
einfach vor entsetzen sind sie jetzt
nach christian linder etwas befriedet
wieder eigentlich eigentlich gar nicht
also ich meine er drückt sich ja genauso
um diese ganze sache herum wie ihr das
gestern auch schon gemacht hat und es
ist ja eigentlich das was es am ende im
prinzip auch so traurig macht diese
ganze sache weil man hat in den letzten
24 stunden unheimlich viele fehler
gemacht zum einen natürlich bei der fdp
in thüringen und dann weiter natürlich
halt auch im parteivorstand
also da hat man ja gesehen im prinzip
wie der stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende wolfgang kubicki
gefeiert hat diesen sieg und wie
christian lindner dann am ende dann doch
eher und diese ganze sache darum
umgekehrt hat als wirklich auch mal
klare kante zu zeigen und das ist das
was die partei eigentlich gestern auch
gebraucht hätte also dass man wirklich
klare kante zeigt dass man sich von
dieser wahl auch ganz klar distanziert
und eigentlich hätte ich mir auch
gewünscht dass er gestern schon thomas
kemmerich aufgefordert hätte das amt
wieder zurückzugeben und das auch ganz
öffentlich groß meint sich der schaden
für die partei
das wird sich jetzt natürlich die
nächsten wochen und monate zeigen wie
groß der schaden am ende sein wird aber
ich denke schon dass viele mitglieder
sich natürlich jetzt erstmal abwenden
weil sie einfach sagen dass zum einen
das was in thüringen passiert ist und
zum anderen was natürlich auch als
reaktion gefolgt ist in berlin dass das
einfach alles nicht irgendwie zusammen
passt und deswegen denke ich schon dass
viele sich jetzt einfach dazu
entscheiden
das parteibuch zurückzugeben und man
kann nur hoffen dass sollte es jetzt
wirklich neuwahlen geben
also ich würde es den liberalen einfache
auch wünschen dass sie halt auch wieder
den sprung in den landtag schaffen weil
sowie das ja jetzt in thüringen war war
das ja mehr als knapp
und da ist die gefahr natürlich relativ
groß dass sie nach eine neue wahl
überhaupt nicht mehr stattfinden